Captain Marvel has started her descent.
The trailer for the 21st entry in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has arrived with explosive
style, and we couldn't be more excited.
So suit yourself up in mohawk mode, and follow
along as we break down all the little details
in the first trailer for Marvel's Captain
Marvel.
Psyche-magne-fragilistic-expialidocious
In the comics, Carol originally received her
powers by being caught in the blast of an
exploding psyche-magnetron ...whatever that
actually is.
At the time, Carol was the head of security
on a US Air Force base.
In the trailer, Carol can be seen in an Air
Force jumpsuit, looking roughed up in the
desert, potentially having just had her plane
shot out of the sky.
Soon after, she's enveloped in some fancy
blue light an all-time classic giveaway for
Made-Up Powerful Comic Book Energy.
Is this the movie version of the exploding
psyche-magnetron, altering Carol's DNA to
give her her powers after crashing to the
Earth during a Kree-Skrull dogfight?
Maybe!
Ronan... we meet again?
The trailer features a familiar silhouette
for MCU fans: sure looks a lot like the return
of Ronan the Accuser, back to life in Captain
Marvel through the magic of the prequel.
This time, the former Guardians of the Galaxy
bad guy technically should be on the side
of the good guys with Carol, considering his
status as a Kree in the Kree Empire.
In the comics, Ronan attempted to overthrow
the Kree Empire, bringing him into conflict
with Mar-Vell.
Whether or not that conflict will be repeated
in this movie remains to be seen.
Origin stories
Carol Danvers' isn't the only origin story
the Captain Marvel movie appears to be remixing.
The movie also seems to be seeding a whole
new origin story for another hero once known
by the name of Captain Marvel.
The trailer shows a chummy relationship with
Carol Danvers and another Air Force pilot
by the name of Rambeau, most likely a reference
to Monica Rambeau, a Marvel Comics character
who technically was the first female Captain
Marvel, taking the name well before Carol
did, since Carol first went by the super-name
Ms. Marvel.
Comics are weird.
All that said, this is not Monica, but rather
a young version of Maria Rambeau Monica's
mother.
Because this movie's a prequel, we may meet
Maria's daughter Monica at some point in this
film...or maybe in a future sequel or spin-off.
There are some Marvelous possibilities...
Skrull and crones
Everyone's going to walk away from this trailer
talking about one moment:
But as you probably suspected, not all is
how it seems.
We're pretty sure the main bad guys of the
movie will be the Skrulls, an intergalactic
warrior race that once did battle with the
Kree.
They've pestered Marvel's superheroes for
years with their numerous attempts to invade
Earth.
The Skrulls appear just before the old lady
in the trailer, implying a connection between
the two.
As you might have surmised, the Skrulls are
shapeshifters, being in their basic forms
humanoid aliens with reptilian or goblin-like
qualities.
So are there secret, shapeshifting Skrulls
already lurking in the Marvel Cinematic Universe?
This movie sure seems to make that a safe
bet...
Target acquired
Captain Marvel is putting Marvel's de-aging
CGI to work to spectacular effect on Samuel
L. Jackson's young, bicloptic Nick Fury, agent
of S.H.I.E.L.D.
From the look of things, Young Fury will spend
the first act of the movie working to track
Carol Danvers down after she busts open that
Blockbuster.
But will they be friends...or foes?
Fury's pager has the answer, as he sends the
message, "With Target"... which is kinda far
off from "With my new pal, Carol."
We know from the end of Infinity War that
the two end up at least as pen pals, but it
will be interesting to see if they face any
opposition from each other on their way to
becoming best buds.
Big guns and green guys
Finally, the first Captain Marvel trailer
also features what appears to be a scene of
Roswell-esque alien dissection, with what
looks like a Skrull's body lying prone on
an operating table while a scrubbed-up doctor
digs in and a G-man-looking gentleman looks
on.
Also present in the shot: Nick Fury, holding
what appears to be, from this distance, a
purple space bazooka.
And an icepack...on his eye...
The arrival of the Skrulls on Earth in the
'90s raises a lot of questions about the MCU
of the now.
The movie will certainly explore their shapeshifting
powers, and the eerie implication is that
there could be spies from another galaxy all
over the MCU we know.
How much do you want to wager that the next
big Marvel guessing game will be "what heroes
have been secret Skrulls this whole time"?